yeah it was kind of expected but you
know what you can save about 420 to just
get started on the last day on Friday
we'll do that probably in Norway and in
Minnesota as well so slightly different
version because we make progress almost
on a daily basis but so should we get
started folks I just need the signal
from them so okay so welcome to
distributed tracing using open census
and I would like to start from the
Lehman law so mayor Lehman was the
professor here in Imperial College in
London and he formulated a set of laws
about software evolution later being
called Lehman laws one of his law said
that the change in software is
inevitable and it's and the software is
gonna change no matter what it doesn't
really depend on a bad design a bad
implementation it just that the software
naturally has to evolve and as a result
it has to change so it's not surprising
that in the last 20 plus years we were
seeing revolution in in software and in
hardware if previously we were running
our code on premises on dedicated
hardware now we do it on the cloud we
were running on virtual machines in the
cloud but today we kind of moved towards
the containers world so that we reduce
the footprint of our workloads and they
improve efficiency
we were running monolith applications
which were deployed as a single unit
were really hard to scale and today we
tend to develop more in the
micro-services style which means that
every micro
this could be developed by a different
team and deployed separately and scaled
in much more efficient way we used to
develop using a single stock single
language and today it's much more common
to see services where you have a go
Python Java and some other languages
mixed together because multiple teams
could create software using different
languages of expertise and so we see
polyglot services we used to run things
in the single cloud but today actually
many companies are looking for moving
into multiple cloud solutions for
redundancy and making sure that their
applications will always work despite
the outages that could happen from time
to time there is even a second layer of
evolution where we move from the
containers world into the server list
world where we don't need to focus on
how to run our infrastructure but we
mostly focus on the actual function that
we want to implement and somebody else
takes care of the infrastructure now
with all those new architectures and the
new evolution curve also new challenges
how do we debug software in this new
world how we detect problems and how do
we understand that the problem has
happened and what that problem could be
how do we develop maybe our development
practices should change as a result of
this evolution how do we package the
software how do we deal with secrets and
configuration management it's a lot of
problems and obviously I can cover all
of that in one lecture so we'll try to
focus today on observability and before
we delve into that I'd like to introduce
myself so I am Simon Seltzer software
engineer working on improving
developer experience with infrastructure
and operations products in Google cloud
so observability what it is
I think the easier
way probably to define that is being
able to debug the system and gain
insights into the system's behavior now
some folks things that observability is
just a new way to say testing or to say
monitoring every couple of years we tend
to invent new terms and we try to kind
of give new meaning into the concepts
that we already know but that is
actually not true and Cindy Frieda run
came up with really nice Venn diagram
that illustrates that observability it's
not just testing and it's not just
monitoring it's about understanding the
root cause of the problem on every
single stage that this problem could
happen before we deployed up their
problem so we do some testing also after
we deploy so we can run some monitors to
detect predicted failures all of the
things are covered in observability so
it's not just a new world now Baron
Schwarz he is very known for his
contributions to my sequel once said
that monitoring tells you whether the
system works observability lets you ask
why it's not working so I think if you
remember that it will give you a really
good picture of what we are going to
talk about now with observability we
usually want to take the holistic
approach we want to gather all the
signals that could be available for our
systems and put them all into the single
timeline be it logs metrics traces
profiling information where we can just
profile the system for CPU and memory
allocation for every method that gets
executed as part of our code passes so
we just want to take all the signals put
them together on the same timeline and
then get some meaning out of that now
what if I tell you that there is
ultimate recipe for making your cloud
services reliable something that will
always work and something that will
always make you successful so it just
three thinks it's very simple
on paper track system house detect
problems and then fix and refine
basically rinse and repeat it's this
cycle that never ends but at the same
time it's just the three simple things
that you need to take care but guess
what it's just like a dream problem so
some people know that if they want to
lose weight they go to gym they need to
practice at least three times a week
probably lose some calories eat healthy
and the results will come but apparently
it's not that easy so apparently the
problem of observability is a hard
problem but it's also an expensive
problem to solve you need to deal with
things like context propagation multiple
environments external dependencies
vendor locking which kind of forces you
to only use what the vendor has to offer
and you can't move out
and of course cost could be an issue as
well so open sensors is our try to get
these problems to a resolution open
census is a single distribution of
libraries in multiple programming
languages that allow you to do metrics
collection and the traces collection for
your air systems it's a single set of
api's which is implemented in eight
languages at the moment including dotnet
core my examples are going to show a
c-sharp but it's also available in other
languages as well sorry
so I digging a little bit more into that
it's a single set of api's for metrics
and traces collection which is
implemented in idiomatic way in every
language that's popular today beat
Python go Java C sharp and so on it has
a lot of integrations with external
systems such as for example if you use
radish cache and you once again some
insights into what is happening as part
of the incoming requests into your
system such that that request could
trigger some activities on
you want to get some insights into
what's going on so open census kind of
provide some integrations which allow
you to get that visibility without
writing any additional code for that it
also implements the context propagation
we have some proposal for how to do it
in a way that's being standardized
across the industry so this context
propagation is implemented across all
different languages and all different
packages that we offer an open census
and it's also a set of exporters which
allow you to take all this observability
information that was collected and then
export it over to one of the backends of
your choice so if you think about the
states before open census you probably
could already use some systems for
metrics collection for traces collection
you still want to continue to use that
but the gain that you get from open
census is that you can instrument you
called one-way no matter what language
you use because the API are identical
and then you can decide where this
information is going to be exported and
then you can change if you want later on
to export it into a different location
but you don't need to instrument your
code all over again not with traces and
not with metrics finally we came up with
this notion of collector for Smart
traces and the metrics ingre Gatien and
I'll show it later on in the demo now
who is behind open census I originally
open census came up from Google's
internal project called census this is
used for as you would imagine traces
collection and Microsoft came up with
very similar ideas so we just joined
forces and some other folks out there in
the observability space joined this
effort as well so we have pretty vibrant
community that has monthly meetings
where we try to progress together it's
all open source so you can join as well
so it got a lot of support it's also not
featuring all of their forms that joined
recently such as dynaTrace
and basically just growing almost on a
daily basis now speaking about open
census in c-sharp you probably want to
know about what nougat packages are
available for you to be able to
instrument your codes for traces and
metrics so there are like over I think
15 packages available today for
different exporters for the core
implementation but these four are the
core that you probably want to to know
about so that you can start using open
census so the first one is open census
dot abstractions which implements the
interfaces which is basically the spec
of open census which is identical
between different programming languages
then we have the open census package
which implements that this interfaces
then if you use HTTP client to make
outgoing HTTP requests and you want to
instrument this request with traces and
metrics you can use open census dot
collector dot dependencies and finally
we have open census collector dot ASP
dot asp net core which is for
instrumenting your SP dodn't core
applications we also plan to shape G RPC
package if you use G RPC for for your
remote procedure calls it is also going
to be possible to instrument your adjure
PC calls from the client to the server
and back with open sensors and it's in
fact already supported in some other
languages ok so let's start talking
about how you actually do get started
with open census for tracing so when you
start with instrumenting your codes with
traces you first need to figure out
what's the architecture and typically
there are two ways that it can go first
is agentless where you have your service
running in the process it could be
hosted on container could be hosted on a
dedicated we have and then your
application amid some traces is the
result of incoming HTTP
and then there is some exporter
component which leaves in your process
which basically collects those traces
and send them over to some external
system the other option is using the
agent so with the agent you have your
application up and running it could be
also running as a separate process but
then the agent is installed side by side
like a separate process it's it has its
pros and cons compared to the agent fest
for example you need to deal with agent
installation which may not be
straightforward in every environment but
at the same time your application is
kind of transparent to tracing it just
emits the traces without knowing who
will collect that and you don't need to
install any dependencies in your
application for being able to collect
those traces out so what we'll do we'll
get started with open census in the
agentless world and then we will kind of
gradually move forward to this other
option as well now before we actually
see the code we should agree on the
terminology so with open census we have
the trace which is basically a
collection of spans the span is the
basic activity that happens is the
result of of the incoming request so in
this case you have messages all
scheduled get my sequel dot query and so
on as separate spans all this together
constitutes one trace then you have
sampler which is a component which
decides whether given trace should be
sent over to back-end or not we'll see
the importance of this component later
on in the demo and finally we have
exporter which is component that
actually sends all these traces that
were collected locally into some
back-end system for tracing now in order
to get started we need to configure
those components that we just spoke
about so first is exporter in my first
demo I'm going to use as
which is open-source tracing system
originated at Twitter so I just create
the exporter passing the exporter
options which is the service that this
trace represents and where this endpoint
that collects the traces is located then
I pass this is tracing dot export
component is open census component which
basically stores all this traces locally
before they are sent over to some
back-end of your choice so after we have
the exporter set up we need to set up
the sampler as as I mentioned before
sampler is a component that decides
where the given trait should be sent
over to the backend or not in this case
there are multiple ways to define the
sampler I'm using configuration here
so the actual sampler setting is here in
the samplers dot always sample open
census library provides multiple default
samplers that you can use such as this
one which samples every single request
for mostly luring purposes you could
also implement your own components the
framework is very flexible so that you
can just implement the right interface
which is defined in the open census dot
project so that when you set the sampler
you can pass your own sampler that just
implements the right interface so once
you have the sampler you get hold the
tracing dot racer which is this
component that actually creates the
traces and finally you start creating
this pads which actually produces this
implementation that we want to get from
the demo what I recommend is always
trying to use a sculpt span which means
that we not only creating the span but
we also limit the start and end time for
that span to the using statement where
it is defined so once this using
statement completes the span will close
and so we
have pretty well defined duration okay
so let's see this in the demo so I'll
quickly go through some of these
components that they just mentioned and
then we'll just execute this demo and
see where is it traced so this is the
exporter piece we define the exporter we
also updated the configuration to use
the sampler which always samples you see
this implements I sampler interface you
could provide your own and then we have
this tracer that we can use we created
sculpt span which is called main and we
do some operation which will happen in
the context of that main span and if we
go into this do work so we can do some
stuff there as well so I get this tracer
in there as well and I can create even
subscribe and sub span so basically this
span will be a child of the previous
span so you can see here we just create
another span and I can in at any point
of time get the context of the current
span where I'm currently running and I
can also do some annotations basically
provide some additional method metadata
about the execution of the current code
pass one of the possible reasons to do
that if you want to add some contextual
information for example the name of the
table when you want to trace some
activity that happens in that table so
it could be really useful information to
have so let's try to run this demo
really quick now I run all my demos in
docker containers so in order to
reproduce the same thing on your machine
you will have to install docker
for desktop and also all this demos as
well as the presentation will be
available later on I'll post it on my a
Twitter and the demos will be available
on their github
okay so we just executed something which
should have produced some traces so
let's try and see how it looks like
so this is Zipkin and this is our
service that we initialized and if you
find traces we can see that it generated
something and you can see here all these
activities of the work that happened
within the parent activity of Maine and
all those things together they
constitute one trace and one single
transaction that happened
I can also double click and get these
annotations that I added in my code so
this is like a simple getting started
with tracing and I could also switch
this zip key and implementation as my
tracing back into something else like
we'll do in other demos
it's
okay so we saw that it's kind of easy to
get started with tracing but there are
some problems that we need to deal with
for example context propagation when you
get a lot of requests that come in
parallel into your system you want to
essentially reproduce the full picture
of what's going on with every single
request so that at the very least you
need to be able to propagate the trace
ad that is associated with the parents
of all this of every single request as
well as all the spans that happen as the
sub activities of that request and so
this pans can span across multiple
components of your system such as here
you can see the front end talking to
checkout talking to an email service you
want to get this entire activity tree
reproduced as a trace in your system in
something like this so for that you need
to be able to pass some information some
of that information could be just
handled by the system such as a trace ad
and the span ad but you may also want to
pass some additional information some
context that should be available in your
other components for example from the
front end you might want to send some
additional information in the traces to
the checkout and then use that
information to make some more decisions
so we need to deal with context
propagation could be very useful in
scenarios of a be testing when you
really want to know when you get from
the front end to the checkout whether
you're executing version a or version B
on the checkout because the whole
activity started probably from where and
a on the front end so it's it could be
really important you know so for that we
have the implementation of w3 standard
that was proposed
jointly by folks from Microsoft Google
and dynaTrace and this star standard is
currently in the last stages of approval
and I'm not going to delve too much into
its details but there is a link in the
slides that you can go and read
what's important is that this standard
is already implemented in all open
source libraries across all the
languages so if you go with open census
for tracing your applications you can be
sure that if you call some external
components which also comply with the
standard you will get more visibility
into those component just naturally by
the fact that you use the same standard
for context propagation as they use okay
so so far we were talking mostly about
tracing but open census is also about
metrics so let's see what we can do with
metrics in order to see the demo for
metrics we need to come up with the
object model which works for metrics as
well so this is the example from stack
driver this is Google's product that
allows you to do a monitoring tracing
performance and debugging and I just
want on this picture to kind of explain
some of these concepts that we'll see in
the code later on so first thing if we
want to measure something we need to
define that entity of what we measure so
in this example it's CPU utilization it
also should include the unit so it could
be percentage it could be just one like
a unit could be other things as well
then when you want to measure CPU
utilization you probably want some
additional contextual information to
understand where it was measured or some
other stuff that will help you then
break it down in the reports so in this
case we might want to record the
instance CD maybe also environment
information so that you can then see
what happens on a given machine as
opposed to environment is the posture
maybe entire cluster later we'll
probably also need to actually take
those measurements these are the points
that essentially you see on the graph so
these are called measurements that they
belong to given measure and you took
this measurements a given point in time
now the graphs cannot represent always
all the measurements that were taken
because maybe the graph represents only
what had
every second so there is a point per
second here but at the same time you
could have taken maybe 50 measurements
in one second so there should be a way
to represent 50 different points in one
point in the graph so for that you need
what's called aggregation aggregation is
a method that basically takes all your
measurements for given period of time
and produces one a point which
represents all those measurements
together so this could be sum of all
those points the minimum the maximum
where a distribution or some other way
for you to kind of decide on a single
point to represent next thing that we
need to cover is a view data so view
data it's basically taking all these
measurements and also providing the
values for all the things that we
mentioned before such as tags the actual
values for tags for every single point
in time that we measure as well as the
values for aggregation you can see view
data as basically all the information
that actually gets collected for your
metrics and then the rest of you in this
case view is is just a definition of
what we intend to collect
so if if you compare view and view data
it's like table schema and table data so
view it's like a table schema it defines
what you want to measure so it has a
name but it also has this measure tag
and aggregation definition what you want
to what you intend to measure and then
the view data is the actual measurements
that you take given this definition of
the view now that we have that we can go
into the demo
so in this demo I'm going to export
information into stock driver and I
could as well export it to primitives
which is open-source system for matrix
collection or some other system which is
commercial it just as easy so in this
case I'm using open census exporter
stock driver as well as open census dot
starts which is the namespace for a
matrix collection matrix and starts it's
basically the same thing as far as
metric collection goes okay so first
thing that we need to do is define what
we measure so this happens here I want
to measure something that I called it
full execution sighs this is description
this is the unit then I want to define
what additional contextual information I
want to send with that measurements so
we have environment and machine these
are just the keys without the actual
value so it's like defining the schema
for for your table without actually
sending the the data for that schema yet
so we define that every measurement
should have environments and machine
name attached to it and then we when we
actually want to send those measurements
we want to calculate the actual machine
name and the actual environment name so
I created this context object which maps
between the tag key to tag value so I
just created here this is my test
environment and I'm sending the actual
machine name now next thing is starts
recorder now start recorder is the
component that stores all this metrics
locally before sending them over to some
back-end so we get hold of this starts
recorder and now we need to configure
well where this information essentially
will go so I'm using a stock driver
exporter and in order to use that you
need to provide the project ID of your
Google Cloud project where all
data is gonna be stored and again if you
use a different exporter it will be
similarly in the way that first you
provide some contextual information to
kind of set up that exporter for example
the end point where all these metrics
will be collected and then you need to
provide what is called the view manager
which holds all those measurements
locally before they they are sent over
to the backend of choice which is stock
driver here now we need to define the
view view in this case is defined like
this this is just the name and the
description this is the measure that we
defined earlier this is the aggregation
function that I'm going to use and these
are the keys that they want to send with
each measurement I need to register that
view so that the local component knows
what to expect when the information is
coming now I'm just executing something
in in a dedicated thread and basically
what they want to do there there is a
method some random method that they
implemented and that method will just
draw a point on a console just for
simplicity and every time the method is
executing I want to record the metric
which counts the number of executions so
the way to do it is just get getting the
instance of what's called stats
recorder and creating the measurement
and the actual value for that
measurement so this is the number of
invocation this is the measurement that
we defined in the first step and one in
this case is the actual value for that
metric at this moment in time and once
we decide to record that we also need to
provide all this contextual information
which we already pre-calculated and put
in the tag context now I realize that
you might see a lot of different steps
to do something relatively simple and
the reason I'm showing so many steps is
because this is basically what always
needs to happen on the
the hood a lot of those things such as
setting up the exporter and making sure
that you can set up the views in much
easier way it's all going to be
abstracted away by the implementation of
our C sharp libraries so that you will
work less but achieve the same things
but I think it's really useful to to see
how all the things look like when you
want to get started literally from zero
so when I execute this application what
you will see is some points starting to
to show up every point means that the
full method was executed and what should
happen behind the scenes is that we keep
recording all those invocations as a
metric and then the stackdriver exporter
component that works as part of our
application it will take all those
measurements and then periodically send
them over to start driver back-end so if
I go to stock driver and we are going to
do that right now
I should expect actually to see that it
should show some graph that represents
this metric that I just collected so I'm
just going to choose monitoring which is
the stock driver monitoring part stock
driver consists of many sub products
that deal with all types of
observability problems so in this screen
basically what I should choose is matrix
Explorer so we send matrix to sent to
stock driver and I should expect to see
my metric feature here in the list and
it was called foo something
let's see sample execution count that's
that's the name okay so what you should
start seeing there is this blue line and
if if we leave it for a long enough
period of time you will see that it
start starts progressing kind of towards
[Music]
that side because essentially all this
measurements are taken as we speak and
the interval at which the stunt driver
graph is updating is 1 minute so it
sends obviously more than one
measurement so over time you will see
that this graph will start changing and
basically it will kind of demonstrate
that we actually take the measurements
and and send them over ok you can see
now that there was some change and if we
keep this working it's just going to
basically evolve as as we speak because
the metal gets executed in a dedicated
thread at some random intervals and this
is why the actual measurements of how
many times the metal was executed at
given moment is going to change
accordingly
ok so let's stop it
okay so let's talk about some other open
census related topics so one of the
latest concepts that we introduced is
open census service open census service
consists of two components agent and
collector now the reason that we came up
with this proposal is that some folks
told us that they prefer to send
information not necessarily to one
exporting component but maybe to
multiple exporters at the same time also
they want to be able to switch the
exporters without restarting their
service on production it could be really
costly to restart your running
application if you just want to send the
monitoring data to to some other
component of your choice so we came up
with this open sense of service solution
where basically you have this open
census libraries in any language you
want to use it and then the libraries
essentially will use open census agents
as their exporter so you will not have
to use different exporters directly in
your code you will use open census agent
as your exporter agent intern will send
information into open census collector
so basically it means that you will need
to install open census collector is
another component now open census
collector could make a decision what to
do with those traces instead of the
agent making the decision and instead of
you making the decision in in the
process where your application is
running and then if you want to add more
exporters you want to export to multiple
observability backends basically you
need to deal with open census collector
there is a llamo file where you can make
your configuration changes and then if
we if we need to restart the component
that sends information to the right
backends of fair choice you just restart
the open census collector but your
system is not impacted in any way so
this is maybe slightly more
sophisticated architecture in terms of
what you need to install
but it has some benefits which is also
includes smart sampling that I'm going
to mention shortly okay so we mentioned
this concept of sampler which is the
component that needs to decide whether
to take this trace and send it over or
not now
traces can be multiple like your
application can generate a lot of traces
and those traces could include many
spans and if all this information is
exported to some back-end of choice you
could pay a lot of money for that so
obviously you don't want to over pay but
also even if we put the pay aside you
can create a lot of noise because if
there are some activities which always
succeed and you trace everything you
don't really need information about
something that always works so you
probably want to skip all this
unnecessary traces and only capture what
you really care about reducing costs and
also reducing the noise so we came up
with a solution to solve that which is
smart sampling and rat 2 ways that you
can do sampling with open sensors or in
general have base sampling and tail
based sampling now we've had by sampling
the sampling decision is happening when
the request comes in
so request comes in there is a component
which is that sampler that we saw before
in the first demo and that component
decides whether to take that trace and
send it over or not which could be nice
because we could just decide to use
sampler which takes maybe some
probabilistic approach like take 10% of
request and sample only them or take
requests that much given a criteria and
then this way just reduce the cost but
in some cases there could be a problem
where there was a decision to trace but
then it's not interesting trace the
other problem that could be is that
request comes in we decided to not trace
that because it's not in this bucket of
10% that we do want to trace and then
basically
the downstream systems where this trace
goes through there there is a problem
and so you will miss this trace because
you took the decision early enough what
we really want to do is take the
decision when we have all the
information and this is where tale base
sampling can really help you be more
efficient so I'm going to show the tale
base sampling and for that I need to do
some warm-up for my demo so I'm going to
start and while it's starting we are
going to talk about the architecture of
this demo so this demo is based on a
sample app that we created at Google
called hipster shop there is a repo for
that demo in the github and you can also
see it
basically it's just a ecommerce
application developed using the modern
cloud stack and there are multiple
components which are all developed using
different programming languages and they
are talking to each other one of those
components is checkout service so when
you hit the front end of this hipster
shop you may want to click on checkout
and do the actual operation of you know
checking out and buying something and
what we want to do in this demo is
basically assimilate what's going on
with traces when this checkout activity
is not always succeeding so what will
happen is this there is a component that
we created that simulates creation of
the loads - - hipster shop application
such that some of the activities will
include errors in the checkout component
some other activities will just succeed
ok now there is we are using here this
open cell census service and the
collector when it gets all these traces
it has to take the decision of whether
to trace all these activities that
happened in hipster shop or not in order
to drum
trait that tail bass sampling is really
effective way we actually try to export
the information to two separate trace
backends in this demo I'm going to use a
Jaeger which is another open-source
tracing system just like Zipkin but this
one was created by uber and basically
the first instance of Jaeger is going to
use head base sampling which basically
means that it will take the decision
whether to trace or not at the early
stage so you can expect to see different
types of traces both with errors in the
checkout as well as without errors in
the checkout and the second instance of
Jaeger is going to use the tale based
sampling where we only trace activities
where spans have errors okay so let's
see it
okay so it's warmed and it's all running
in containers who can reproduce it
anywhere and the instructions will be
posted on github alongside this
presentation so I'm going to open the
first instance of Jager and here are all
these services of the hipster shop one
of them is the checkout service
did it click okay so when I look at the
traces for the checkout service or that
involve checkout service you can see
that there are mixed races some of them
don't include any broken spans or spans
with errors
some of them do include spans with
errors okay so it's really mixed because
the traffic in some cases and simulates
errors in some cases it doesn't simulate
the errors if we go to the second
instance of Jaeger let's do it here and
we also open the traces you see much
less traces and every single activity
that was captured here that involves the
checkout it also involves some errors so
basically given the same volume of trace
information that came into the collector
service in this case we were able to
collect much more important information
first because we use tale based sampling
where we only sample the cases where
errors happen in our Spence
look at some more concepts that opens
answers introduces that also originated
at Google the pages so in Google what we
have in some internal systems is the
ability to understand on the given
machine when the traffic hits that
machine
what traces are captured on that
specific machine so basically you can
just go into slash trace Z or RPC see
depends on what type of communication
framework is used with that machine and
get all this information because it's
actually something that is hosted in in
the libraries that we use for
instrumentation so you just get it kind
of for free by a mere fact that your
instrument using open sensors libraries
now it's not available yet in c-sharp
but it's available in Java yo and some
other languages and will be available in
c-sharp as well just like any other
functionality so you will get this just
by using the right instrumentation
libraries now we have the metrics of
what exporters are available T is for
trace exporters as is for stats or
metrics exporters across different
languages now you see that it's not full
and we working on improving that across
all different languages that we want to
support as well as major Beck and
components for observability that once
you have their presence in this open
census ecosystem but it's improving
literally on a daily basis so we'll get
there and it will be fuller as we
progress we also have some existing
pre-built integrations so if you use one
of these components and this is not the
full list basically these are already
pre instrumented with open sensors so if
you depend on these components and your
stock is already instrumented with open
sensors you will get visibility not only
into what your activities
doing but also what this external
components are doing because they
implement the same trace context
propagation and they also provide you
some of this metric views which already
kind of pre pre build by folks that
created this integrations in the first
place
and of course we want to improve this
and build more and more integrations one
of the interesting examples is Google
Cloud basically just by mere fact that
you ran in Google Cloud
we will detect automatically all these
tags that represents the environment
where you are running so we can detect
that you are running on Google
kubernetes engine or Google App Engine
or some other environment could be just
VM and attach these tags into every
single span that gets created so you
will get a lot of this helpful
information without doing anything okay
so open census has pretty active
community we have this open census dot
your website guiter channel we develop
in the multiple github repos it's
basically divided by different languages
that we support so I take a look I hope
that you can also join and help us
improve and progress the community meets
once a month its public meeting that you
all can join we have pretty substantial
improvements in the last year 2018 and
we want to do even more in 2019 one of
the main focuses that we are going to
work on this year is improving their
ease of use as you could see in the
second demo of the metrics there are a
lot of steps that you need to do to be
able to accomplish relatively simple
tasks we want to reduce that so that you
almost don't need to do anything and you
will still get a lot of information and
insights from your system if your
instrumented with
open census we also want to enhance the
feature set across all different
languages that we support so that there
will be no gaps in functionality between
the languages you can use in any
language you want building strong
community CN CF is one of the directions
that we want to go maybe except they're
trying to accept this project into CN CF
as well as you might heard about open
tracing which is another try to kind of
standardize on how do you do at tracing
across the industry they share a lot of
very similar goals but the only cover
tracing whereas open census covers
metrics and also logs in the future so
we want to basically get together and
make sure that there is one standard
that works for all and in progress over
there so I encourage you to give it a
try and join the work and with that I'd
like to thank you and have any questions
I'm here yeah
[Music]
so yeah it really depends on what suck
do you use and what circumstances for
example if you develop in c-sharp and
use asp.net course so you can plug your
tracer into the dependency injection of
HP dotted core and then you have this
eye tracer available everywhere so you
can just use the eye tracer dot create a
new span and take it from there
basically just one API call to create
the trace also we are planning to have
the basic HTTP operations as well as G
RPC operations already pre instrumented
so all you will need to do is just to
say something like ads open census
extension methods where you just say how
do you want to sample that who is your
exporter and we'll take it from there
basically so every incoming request into
your asp.net core application will be
automatically instrumented so we'll
create a span for you the name of the
span will be as the name of the request
that that isn't coming to you like slash
messages or whatever and then if if your
code is making outgoing requests and you
use beat HTTP client or you use share PC
client for making outgoing RPC calls we
will also instrument that as well so you
just create those clients in advance
when you once you register all your
components in dependency injection and
once you get and that instance through
dependency injection it's already pre
set up with with tracing and you can
also do the same thing with metrics so
basically the majority of the common
stuff you will be able to do maybe like
with two or three lines of code at the
startup time when you just say who is
your exporter and how to sample that but
if you want to do something more because
with traces you're not only limited to
tracing the HTTP stack you can also
trace some logical activities that
happen in your application so it will
also be like one API call away
okay so the span can span exposes so is
the word different components in your
whole architecture so let's say if
you've got your web service is calling -
you know another component on a
different machine and they can all you
couldn't follow the trace from yeah yeah
so basically the trace is your entrant
activity so say someone makes a request
to google.com and basically this
triggers the start of the trace but then
there are a lot of internal systems that
are involved in producing that response
for you so you can think that every
system like that will produce at least
one span which kind of describes the
activity of that subsystem so when when
there is incoming requests to that
subsystem it basically starts their span
it does what whatever it does and then
when it finishes it ends the activity
for that span now all those pans are
sent to the tracing back end as in since
every single span includes the
information about the trace ad and and
the parent for every span only the first
span doesn't have a parent which is the
initialization of the full transaction
so basically you will get all of this
representation of what's going on in the
tracing back end just because they all
follow the same object model so all this
trace tracing back ends will be able to
represent that in in the same way more
or less okay yeah
yes so I think I'm not sure if it's
already supported specifically Kafka but
I think there is plan to support it just
like any sort party integration so we do
want to to be able to instrument all
those things in a way that you just
declare in your court that I do want to
get those traces or I do want to get
metrics from those external systems and
it will just happen and you will have a
speck which defines what you should
expect to get especially for for their
metrics III can give example with ERP C
and HTTP but it should hold the same
with also party integrations for example
if you want to measure the quality of
service of incoming calls into that
third party there is a view definition
that will say what are the metrics that
will be collected by this third party
component so if you enable open census
metrics for that component there is some
implementation that you would be able to
find through this open census echo
system but that implementation will just
guarantee that this metrics get produced
for you and you just define where you
want to send this matrix what is your
exporter and you will just get all that
information and be able to create the
graphs even though it's external
component for you so even if it's a
message broker yes we would still want
to take care of that okay cool thank you
well so it supports profiles so you can
have work profile and personal profile
token of thanks from the NDC to charity
that they support thank you very much
thank you
so actually we do yes so we do support
even its it may sound a bit weird but we
support starting from 4.5 which is not
officially supported by Microsoft and
the reason for that is that Microsoft
folks said that a lot of people still
used 4.5 and they don't want to lose
those people because essentially the
story is you use something old which may
not be supported and in order to migrate
that into something newer you at least
want to get the visibility on what it's
doing right now and then start your
migration story so this is why they want
to provide this observability into
slightly older stock than what they
officially support so that you can get
started with a really good picture and
just move forward
actually was started at core the
libraries weren't ready so he wrote it
framework now we just want to add some
like quite big so we do want to move
yeah so it it is definitely supported
now but the only acre-feet to that is
that not all the exporters have support
for Boston framework and not not core
it works but I mean with rotten frame of
the regular one but I need to double
check if all the specs for primitives
work like I remember there was a recent
bug like from a few weeks ago where if
you want to host primitives exporter
there is this way of like exporting your
metrics so that primitives can grab them
and it uses port so in some cases of
azure websites they may not allow you to
export the separate ports you need to
export it on the same ports as your
application so there are some folks
working on there fixing that so it in in
general it's supported but we need to
see the details if it really matches
your use case thanks thanks
I hope that I mean as I felt like it
started not well but then it progressed
better